[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
i think from day one
everyone's wanted justice for your wife
emily
but i think the jury has also said
justice family is not injustice for you
a verdict is handed down in ohio versus
matthew moore and the defendant presents
his own closing argument while standing
trial for attempted murder i do ask you
to please
find me innocent of
the charges against me plus a win on the
books for disgraced hollywood producer
harvey weinstein as a new york judge
grants an appeal marking the first step
towards a possible new trial and later
the parkland school shooter penalty
phase trial this boy did not go bad he
was never right a recap of the defense's
case so far long crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everybody to law and crime daily
i'm your host terry austin after just
three hours of deliberations a not
guilty verdict is handed down in the
ohio trial of matthew moore following
days of testimony over charges for the
2020 alleged stage suicide death of his
wife emily noble
over the last week and a half
prosecutors questioned dozens of
witnesses in an attempt to prove moore
killed noble in may 2020 but prosecutors
said he staged her murder to look like a
suicide during the four months she was
missing several search parties looked
for the 52-year-old although her husband
reportedly never helped her remains were
found in september of that year in a
wooded area near the couple's home she
was found kneeling beneath the tree with
the usb cord attached to a branch and
wrapped around her neck the defense
called just two witnesses to argue their
theory that the evidence points to noble
killing herself jury deliberations began
thursday afternoon and lasted just three
hours before the jury came to a decision
the verdict was read early friday
morning by the judge
verdict on count one
we the jury being duly impaneled sworn
final defendant matthew l moore not
guilty of murder as he stands charged in
count one of the indictment verdict on
count two
we the jury being duly impaneled and
sworn find the defendant matthew l moore
not guilty of murder as he stands charge
in count two of the indictment verdict
on count three we the jury being duly
impaneled and sworn finding defendant
matthew moore not guilty of felonious
assault as he stands charged in count
three of the indictment mr moore
i think from day one
everyone's wanted justice for your wife
emily
and i've heard that phrase a lot and i
think everyone truly desires that
but i think the jury has also said
justice family is not injustice for you
thursday afternoon both sides presented
closing arguments the prosecutor told
jurors the defense's case is not what
actually happened
the person who has repeatedly triumphed
over trauma in her life
the person who has sought treatment the
person who is by the defendant's own
words is not depressed or had never said
anything that would have caused him to
call law enforcement to try to get his
wife help that she was going to harm
herself the person who just went out to
celebrate her birthday who's celebrating
a special time of year in her life
she
wakes up randomly in the morning
never touches her phone to respond to
any other questions or comment or text
that she'd received
makes herself a drink
makes the bed
and waters off into the woods to hang
herself
really
what part of that
is a reasonable explanation
of what happened
emily
noble's death was not suicide
moore's defense attorney highlighted key
points of the defense argument during
her closing saying the state did not
prove beyond a reasonable doubt that
moore killed his wife
he takes them
to the exact area
and says this is where she forages and
then even the state of ohio and their
closing argument just now had to concede
that you know what he says
you might want to go in
oh
that's a bad fact right
and you know why he wouldn't want to go
in
is it because he doesn't want to find
her
actually
i agree with that
you know why does he want to find her
because 10 months earlier his son was
hanging
from a tree
in the woods
i wouldn't want to go in a wooded area
either
this has all been made out to be so
horrific right
what really happened is emily went to
nature to find her peace
and you'll see that the counseling
records
that that's where she found peace
she went there
and she grabbed her ankles and you know
why she grabbed her ankles
so that she wouldn't stop herself from
kept on herself
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney mike corbonics and trial
attorney catherine lizardo catherine
let's start with you the jury only took
three hours to reach a not guilty
verdict on all counts were you surprised
not at all terry
dayan menashe did a spectacular job with
her closing statement there
and it's it was so enthralling you
cannot take your eyes off of her she was
so good at presenting the facts and had
such command of the facts that she
didn't even need notes and you can see
her there vol
moving her arms really showing the jury
how can you possibly do this uh in terms
of the usb cord wrapping it around your
neck
it's possible and our experts showed
that the tree hanging
can actually support her weight
so the state really provided so many
reasonable doubts so many holes and the
fact of the matter that she said that in
the woods
uh they did not search that area
that's a big mistake by the
investigators and yes the state actually
uh agreed with that and acknowledged
that but
having all that four months before they
found her a lot could have happened to
her body that could cause the fractures
that we're talking about absolutely no
doubt now mike let me ask you the judge
told mr moore that justice for emily you
heard him say this does not mean
injustice for you do you think the jury
got it right or did moore simply have
great representation
i think
probably both but i thought that was a
very powerful statement by a judge to
say because
when he said that
he really affirmed i think his belief
because and his agreement with the jury
because he said that there would be an
injustice if you were convicted and that
really stood behind the juries and
saying he believed their verdict i agree
that was a great statement still ahead
on long crime daily new york's highest
court agrees to hear an appeal by
disgraced movie mogul harvey weinstein
but first hear from both sides as
closing arguments are presented in the
attempted murder trial of trevor summers
[Music]
welcome back defendant trevor summers
decides not to testify but does present
a closing argument on his own behalf
officials say summers and then wife
alisa matheson were in the midst of
divorce proceedings when he hacked a
murder-suicide plot they say summers
held his wife captive in her home and in
the back of her suv attempting twice to
kill her before a witness facilitated an
escape on friday prosecutors presented
their closing argument
quoting miss mathewson
all i saw was an expression of evil and
hatred
and at that time
i thought he's here to kill me
i'm going to die
and as she sees that look on his face
she notices he has something he is
hiding behind his back
he then comes over to her
as she is on the bed tied up
and puts the pillow over her face
she starts struggling so what does he do
he then gets on top of her
straddling her applying more pressure to
that pillow
to the point where she is thinking to
herself
she knew where she was going
she was going to meet jesus
summers opted to represent himself
meaning he cross-examined his ex-wife
and two of his children when it came
time for the defense closing summers
himself presented the argument
gentlemen
reasonable doubt i believe is everywhere
and i ask you
to please remember that and please focus
on that
that element that has to be proven by
the time that you make these decisions
about my life about
the situation
that
you've been presented
about deciding whether or not to find
the innocent or guilty
i ask you to please consider all of
these factors and see that what i am
trying to
show you
is that
this was a very abnormal
series of events and it requires a lot
more information for you to draw a
conclusion that would say that i
absolutely am guilty of these crimes
all right mike trevor summers did his
own closing statement but he clearly
lacked knowledge of the law for instance
he kept asking the jury to find him
innocent when we all know the correct
phrase is not guilty overall how did he
do
not well not well it's very difficult in
these kind of situations when you're
representing yourself because
it puts you right in the middle of
things and the jury isn't
wondering where you got your information
from they're saying you're the accused
you have information
and you're basing your questions on that
information so it almost turns a
cross-examination
if you're if you are representing
yourself pro se as testimony
and his cross-examination with her
really was not good testimony especially
when she refused to look at him so i
don't think it worked well or was a good
strategy i agree 100
and he kept getting interrupted with
objections because he kept saying things
that weren't in evidence catherine the
prosecution emphasized that trevor
summers admitted to several crimes
including tying up his ex-wife how do
you think this all male jury remember
it's all men how do you think they're
responding
i think they will respond to their
common sense
as to what should what was happening and
what the facts were state or telling
them because they will apply the facts
and the law and see that the verdict
will
very likely be guilty because like what
the prosecutor said he admitted to being
manipulative and controlling in one of
his
video and interviews and that is the
theme of this case manipulative and
controlling hubris will be his downfall
here especially when he represented
himself absolutely the prosecution
mentioned 16 years he was being
controlling and she finally was able to
speak out at this trial so
coming up on long crime daily defense
attorneys narrow in on the parkland
school shooter's childhood
plus a win for harvey weinstein a new
york court agrees to hear his appeal as
he tries to overturn his 2020 sex crimes
conviction
[Music]
welcome back the department of justice
released a 38-page redacted affidavit
friday detailing evidence that led to
the fbi surge of donald trump's
mar-a-lago home the agent seized
multiple boxes containing classified
documents judge bruce reinhardt ordered
the doj to actually redact portions of
that affidavit to protect the integrity
of the investigation
the doj also filed a memorandum of law
outlining a timeline and explaining the
risks of releasing the affidavit
including witness retaliation and
disclosure of sources and methods
and moving up the east coast to new york
disgraced hollywood movie mogul harvey
weinstein is granted the right to an
appeal more than two years after his
conviction of sexual crimes
weinstein was found guilty of third
degree rape and first degree criminal
sexual act but acquitted of three more
serious charges back in february 2020
capping a landmark trial of the metoo
era he was sentenced to 23 years in
prison the decision now opens the door
for oral arguments before the new york
state court of appeals next year
weinstein and his attorneys argue that
the film producer did not receive a fair
trial and they aimed to reverse his
conviction entirely after hearing
arguments the court could either uphold
the lower court's decision and keep
weinstein's conviction in place or
vacate his conviction that could lead to
a modified conviction or a new trial
catherine if weinstein is actually
granted a new trial do you think his
accusers including miriam haley and
jessica mann will testify again
i think that they will especially miss
haley and miss mann those are the two
witnesses two key witnesses against
harvey weinstein and as you can see
there
miss haley is represented by gloria
allred and miss already mentioned in her
press conference before that if there
was an appeal and there was a new trial
that miss haley will testify again so i
think there is a high likelihood that
she will miss man i think will also
testify again she has been involved in a
lot of reforms of the laws regarding the
definition of consent
so that there are changes nationwide so
these two are very courageous women and
i think they will still face their acute
their
harvey weinstein if there is a new trial
again it's got to be hard though
catherine's saying on that stand again
and actually going through all of that
and being convincing but i agree i think
they will get back up there mike harvey
weinstein's planning to argue that a
juror who wrote a book about a predatory
older men
should have been excluded from the jury
could that actually make a winnable
ground for appeal
i think it makes a justifiable
justifiable issue to discuss on appeal
however whenever you're looking to
overturn a juror or something of that
nature it's very difficult and one of
the really reasons it's so difficult is
when you look at it it has to be a
unanimous verdict so not only do you
have to show that the juror hid
something but the the thing that he hid
was used to find a conviction but it's
difficult to show that if 11 other
people found that he was guilty of the
charges that he is accused of
yeah i agree with you 100 mike that
makes complete sense listen when we come
back a closer look at the parkland
school shooters childhood years hear
from two witnesses who knew the
defendant in his early years and how
they described his upbringing
welcome back in the first week of the
defense's case jurors learn about the
gunman's childhood and mental state in
the parkland school shooter penalty
phase trial last year the gunman pleaded
guilty to 17 counts of murder and 17
counts of attempted murder after the
deadly shooting at marjory stoneman
douglas high school jurors will now
decide whether the defendant receives
life in prison or the death penalty
defense attorneys finally presented an
opening statement on monday weeks after
the trial first began they outlined the
gunman's difficult upbringing and
unstable mental state calling multiple
witnesses who supported that narrative
even after she told you that she was
pregnant did you see her continue
absolutely
alcohol absolutely drugs alcohol weed
cigarettes linda didn't see anything
wrong
didn't what she didn't want to see
anything wrong with him but that's not
unusual
and when you try to have these
conversations with her was she receptive
no he was talking about that something
made him go bad and he mentioned
marijuana
and i knew right away i said that's not
true
that's not true he was never right it
wasn't marijuana that changed him he was
never right
catherine let me start with you defense
counsel is trying very hard to save the
defendant's life how do you think this
jury is actually responding to all of
this evidence about his mother's drug
use especially when she was pregnant
with him
i think now the jury's state of mind is
shifting
towards those very sad and tragic
mitigating factors that the defense is
rightfully putting in front of them that
we are not hearing anymore the horrific
uh shooting and the videos that we've
been seeing before
before during the prosecution's case and
it's it's a good tactic that the defense
had their opening right after all of
those horrific facts and evidence were
presented now the jury has
has the opportunity to shift their minds
and here i think there will be a lot of
sympathy for the defendant because of
the drug use of his mother and other
factors such as as we saw the testimony
of that neighbor saying that he just
didn't look right even
as he was growing up so
yeah it's so interesting you should say
that catherine because i was actually
thinking that it was a good idea to wait
to do the defense opening i think others
thought it was not but either way we'll
see what the jury decides at the end of
the day and mike you know even if the
jury ultimately does agree that he
should get the death penalty there is
going to be all kinds of lengthy appeals
don't you think
yeah absolutely this is going to be a
very long process if he gets
found where they believe the death
penalty applies because
usually death penalty cases have so much
exhaustion of appeals which they should
to make sure if you're going to kill
somebody there's not a mistake being
made but in furtherance too let's not
forget
this a lot of this occurred in the
judicial part during the pandemic and
the whole united states regardless of
states have been backed up because of
the pandemic and how things have caused
delays so this will be even more so
interesting because the appeals courts
absolutely have backups right so even if
he gets the death penalty we might not
see anything for years and years thank
you both for excellent commentary and
thank you for joining us here on long
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we all discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you